امكانيه الوصول الى هدنه وصفقه كيف تبدو
لك
الان تحياتي لك وساده المشاهدين اعتقد ان
هذا الحراك المتسارع على مستوى الاقليم
يوحي بان الصفقه والهدنه تقترب نوعا ما
ولكن لا يمكن اغفال العديد من الفجوات
والعقبات او اولى هذه العقبات تتصل
بالحاله الاسرائيليه الداخليه التي عبرت
عنها تصريحات نتنياهو المتناقضه اليوم
وخلال الايام الفائت نتنياهو يحاول ان
يمسك العصى من المنتصف بين الضغوط
الامريكيه وبين المتطلبات الامريكيه بهذا
السياق وبين ايه ال الحسابات الداخليه
سياسيا وايضا يضع بعين الاعتبار حسابات
متصله باهالي الاسرى وبالتالي هو يقدم هذه
التصريحات التي تبدو متناقضه في كثير من
الاحيان ومن هنا تاتي الضغوط الداخليه
لبيد اليوم يقول انه يمكن ان يوفر شبكه
امان بالنسبه لنتنياهو وهذه رساله يمكن ان
يستخدمها نتنياهو صحيح بمواجهه الامين
المتطرف لكن هو يعلم انه حتى وان حصل على
دعم لبيد فان لبيد هو خصم سياسي لدود
بمعنى ان هذه حاله من الامان المؤقت لا
يمكن الارتهان لها لمستقبله السياسي في ظل
كل ما ينتظر بعد هذه الحرب وبالتالي هذا
المشهد معقد اسرائيليا ايضا السؤال المتصل
بماذا بعد بمعنى ان الحديث ايه كما قالت
المقاومه منذ البدايه يجب ان يكون عن وقف
لاطلاق النار وليس عن هدنه مؤقته هذا سؤال
مهم جدا يحتاج لاجابات وا اعتقد ان الحديث
اليوم الذي برز عن
ضمانات اقليميه
وامريكيه لهذه الهدنه والحديث عن حاله
تهدئه اعتقد انه ياتي بسياق البحث عن مسار
بديل يمهد ربما لوقف اطلاق نار ولكن ليس
بطريقه انيه ومباشره ا طيب من بين ما قاله
نتنياهو ايضا يعني هو يريد الوصول الى
صفقه لا تضر كما يقول بامن اسرائيل وان
ادت لانهيار حكومته هل هنا يلمح لامر
ما يعني هو يحاول ان يقدم نفسه على انه
مستعد للتضحيه بهذا الاتجاه ولا يقدم
الحسابات الشخصيه وال الحسابات الانتخابيه
على المصلحه القوميه
ولكن ما يعرفه او ما تحدث عنه على انه
ثوابت بالنسبه له هي قضايا تفجر
الانتخابات هو يريد لهذه عفوا المفاوضات
هو يريد لهذه الصفقه ان تفشل ولكن لا يريد
ان يتحمل المسؤوليه وبالتالي هو يضع
العراقيل بوجه هذه المباحثات بمعنى انه
يتحدث عن رفضه للافراج عن اعداد كب كبيره
الاف من الاسرى الفلسطينيين كما وصف وهذه
نقطه اساسيه لا يمكن تجاوزها على الاقل
على سبيل المثال هذه من بين جمله قضايا
تحدث عنها ويرفض وقف اطلاق النار بشكل
دائم اي هذه كلها قضايا
تعرقل المباحثات واعتقد انها تضع ايضا
ضغوط على الاطراف الوسيطه وتغضب الجانب
الامريكي وهذا يزيد من غضب الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه نتنياهو وان كان هذا
غير معلن ايضا لا يمكن اهمال الرسائل التي
جاءت من واشنطن اليوم بالحديث عن بدء
التفكير ب الاعتراف بدوله
فلسطينيه بشكل مبكر بمعنى الذهاب الى
مقاربه جديده بالتعامل مع هذا الملف هذه
رسائل تضغط على نتنياهو وعلى الجانب
الاسرائيلي بشكل اكبر تضغط باي شكل سيد
ابراهيم يعني هو يقول ويؤكد مره اخرى بانه
لن يدفع اي ثمن مقابل هذه الصفقه ويؤكد
على خطوط حمر مره اخرى لانسحاب وان الحرب
ستستمر حتى القضاء على حماس وبالتالي لا
نرى اي نتيجه ربما لهذا الضغط الذي تشير
اليه بالتالي اي سيناريو نذهب اليه بشان
هذه الصفقه واي شكل
لها علينا ان ندرك ان هنالك العديد من
اللاعبين السياسيين في الحربه السياسيه
الاسرائيليه منهم اعضاء مجلس الحرب جانس
وايزن جووت الذين ربما يختلفون مع ياه
بهذه النقطه والذين قد يضغطوا عليه بشكل
او باخر هذا من جانب من جانب اخر هنالك
عمليه تسويات ربما يبدا بها نتنياهو مع
اعضاء ائتلافه صحيح ان الضغط ياتي من
قواعد الليكود ومن اليمين المتطرف
المتحالف معه ولكن ايضا كما تعودنا في
الصفقات في الصفقه السابقه كان الخطاب
عالي قبل هذه تلك الصفقه ولكن بعد ذلك
بدات اللغه تنخفض تدريجيا وقدمت الصفقه
على انها جاءت بسبب الانجازات الميدانيه
للجيش ولكن بالنهايه تمت تلك الصفقه
والهدنه
لفتره وبالتالي هذا يخضع لمنظومه التسويات
التي تتم بين اطراف الائتلاف الحاكم اليوم
ايضا الرساله والضغط الذي جاء برساله
اللبيد تحديدا اعتقد انها رساله يمكن ان
يست نتنياهو بمواجهه حلفاؤه بانه في حال
انسحبت من هذه الحكومه كما تهدد هنالك من
يحمي الذهب الى صفقه